bien sûr que c'est un progrès dans la
dans contrôle démocratique et dans la
morale publique c'est un progrès qui est
d'ailleurs du aux conséquences que
François Hollande à tirer de l'affaire
Cahuzac dans le précédent quinquennat
c'est l'application de cette nouvelle
législation ensuite j'ai bien entendu
que Marc Fesneau nous disait circuler il
y a rien à voir c'est un non-événement
en réalité c'est un événement la
démission de Alain grise et aujourd'hui
après sa condamnation c'est la moindre
des choses et moi je pense qu'il aurait
dû démissionner après sa mise en examen
comme c'était le principe qui avait été
dicté depuis le gouvernement Lionel
Jospin et donc c'est un principaux
qu'elle s'est tenu Emmanuel Macron au
début de son quinquennat je crois que
plusieurs ministres et pas des moindres
en ont fait les frais François Bayrou
exactement ensuite il s'en est
affranchis il n'y a aucune ligne de
conduite et au total un vrai recul je
crois pour la crédibilité de notre moral
public je pense que c'est un vrai recul
qui est intervenu dans ce
aujourd'hui Alain Griset démissionne
peut-être que ce n'était pas un ministre
très connu mais ça n'est pas un nom des
événements comme essaie de nous dire le
gouvernement c'est un événement
important
[Musique]